ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBERS AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MADAM CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES SAYS
CHAU. CHAVEZ CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DAHLE.
DALY.
EGGMAN
FLORA.
FONG
FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI. NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON.
QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA. REYES BATTERY DOES
RUBIO.
SOLACE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER.
WOOD. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND PATTY OSHA.
REDUCED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THE BUDDHA ONCE SAID THAT WE
WILL LIVE TWO LIVES.
THE SECOND ONE BEGINS WHEN WE
REALIZE THAT WE WILL HAVE ONLY
ONE LIFE.
WHEN WE LIVED TAKING FOR GRANTED
THE DAYS WE ARE ABLE TO LIVE.
AND NOT TRULY APPRECIATING THE
PEOPLE WHO EACH DAY. GIVE
MEANING TO OUR LIVES.
WE ARE LIVING A DREAM.
WE ARE IMAGINING WE WILL NEVER
RUN OUT OF TIME.
AND EVERYTHING WILL ALWAYS BE AT
THE VERY LEAST AS GOOD AS IT IS
RIGHT NOW.
THE ONE WE AWAKEN FROM THIS
ILLUSION OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
IT IS THEN. THAT WE BEGIN TO
LIVE THE LIFE THE GIFT OF THIS
ONE AND ONLY LIFE.
WITH EVER DEEPENING
APPRECIATION.
THE BUDDHA ONE SAID.
THAT WE WILL LIVE TWO LIVES.
THE SECOND ONE BEGINS
WHEN WE REALIZE THAT WE HAVE
ONLY ONE LIFE.
NO MORE WE DON'T SEE. WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY AS SHE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER AGUILAR OCCUR.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
REALLY OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY EIGHTEEN BE DAHLE
MET AT NINE A. M. HONOR LAURA
FRIEDMAN ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO
TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING
CHEAPER E. DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK. IT IS. AS A PARODY
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAN.
WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
AND MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSIGNMENT
AYE I'M I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS LACKEY AND
BLOOM TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN
MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH A BE THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY NINE MCCARTY FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE OBERNOLTE FROM THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY NINE CAMBIADO FROM THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SIX LEVINE FROM THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
TO THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. AND AB THIRTY ONE
NINETY NINE HOLDEN FROM THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONAL
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS. PENDING RE
REFERRAL AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN IRWIN PENDING RIP REFERRAL
FROM AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE.
EXCUSE ME AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
AND AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE
AND A GARCIA PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PLACE ITEM TWENTY NINE ACR ONE
FIFTY THREE SANTIAGO. ON THE
FIRST DAY CONSENT CALENDAR THE
RESOLUTION WAS MISTAKENLY
REPORTED TO THIRD READING.
WORK WILL KNOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
AT THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON PLEASE REMOVE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE RADIUS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
QUIRK WILSON NO
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY.
MISTER CALDERON I BELIEVE YOUR
GUESTS HAVE ARRIVED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I.
AM PLEASED TODAY TO WELCOME
SOME GAS FOR MY DISTRICT TO THIS
TO THE ASSEMBLY FROM THE
HACIENDA LAPOINTE THEY ADULT
EDUCATION.
IF.
NEED YOU GUYS TO PLEASE STAND
AYE I DO APPRECIATE A JOINING US
TODAY WE HAVE.
ALICE YA COTA YOSHIKO.
YOU SHOW I GOT.
DEPARTMENT CHAIR BUSINESS
CAREERS DEPARTMENT AT OUR OUR
GOTTA ADMINISTRATOR FOR H. LP AB
VALERIE CLIPPER COUNSELOR.
BRICK MANRIQUE AS AND SANDEEP
SINGH GUPTA.
WHO ARE INSTRUCTORS AND TO TELL
ME CANTO?
WHO IS AN OFFICE ASSISTANT AS
WELL AS DID NAY PONCE ONLY
HUNDRED THE CS AND MARKER RIO
WHO ARE STUDENTS OUT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THE POINT AT ALL EDUCATION
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
THEM TO THE IT'S?
I'M ALSO GOING TO RECOGNIZE MR
MCCARTY WHO HAS GAS HERE.
RELATIVE TO ADULT EDUCATION
WEEK FROM MISTER DOUGHTY'S
GAS.
THIS IS MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU WE DON'T OUT STATES
THAT.
WE DON'T UP STAYS THE HACIENDA
LA WEDNESDAY. LEADERS HERE BUT
WE ALSO UP WHERE SOME ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THIS IS ADULT
EDUCATION WEEK.
RIGHT.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
YOU.
APPLAUSE FOR MINIMUM LOW YES
SO WHAT I THINK YOU.
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS STATE
ADULT EDUCATION WHO WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO BRING LIGHT
CHANGING ADULT.
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES TO
STUDENTS TAKING HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMAS.
JEEZ BASIC READING WRITING
SKILLS AND ENGLISH LANE ENGLISH
LEARNING CLASSES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK.
AND MS FRIEDMAN YOU HAVE GUESTS
WITH US TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM VERY PROUD TO
INTRODUCE SOME VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY.
FOR BRAVE WOMEN WHO HAVE SPOKEN
OUT AGAINST
GENEROSITY
COLLEGE ATHLETICS.
PLEASE WELCOME GENET AND TOLAND
FORMER U. S. GYMNASTICS NATIONAL
TEAM MEMBER AN INTERNATIONAL
COMPETITOR. JAMIE DAMN SURE A
BRONZE MEDALIST IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SUMMER OLYMPICS IN
SYDNEY. JORDAN WEAVER A GOLD
MEDALIST IN THE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE SUMMER OLYMPICS IN LONDON
AND TIFFANY THOMAS LOPEZ A
FORMER SOFTBALL PLAYER FOR
MICHIGAN STATE. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY AND FOR
YOUR EXTRAORDINARY LEADERSHIP
FIGHTING.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISS
BECOME MEMBERS AND IN SUPPORT
AND AND ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS WE ALSO DID
A STATE OF THESE FINE YOUNG
WOMAN THAT WE TALK A LOT ABOUT.
PORTS AND TITLE NINE HOWEVER WAS
GETTING INVOLVED AND THEN WHEN
THEY DO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE PROTECTED ALL THE WAY
THROUGH SO WE THANK YOU FOR.
COURAGE AND SPEAK
NOW
AND MAKING SURE THAT SPORTS
REMAINS FREE FOR ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE BILL PARTICIPATE TO THE
FULLEST OF THEIR POTENTIAL THANK
YOU
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
CALDERON YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER.
THE FOLLOWING BILL TO COMMITTEE
AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE MATHIS
FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
MISS WALDRON FOR PURPOSE OF WE
OBJECT TO THAT MOTION AND ASK
FOR ROLL CALL.
MISS WALDRON OF JACK'S THIS IS A
MOTION TO RE REFER MOVED BY
MISTER CALDERON.
SECOND BY MISTER TANG MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE. ON
THE MOTION TO RE REFER HER A. B.
TWENTY. EIGHTY NINE MEMBERS THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
IN THIS CASE MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MISS
WALDRON IS ASKING FOR A NO. VOTE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
I. VOTES AND MS WALTERS ASKING
FOR NO MISTER CALDERON TASK FOR
AND I.
THIS TAKES FORTY ONE ON THE
MOTION A RE REFER MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
AND MISS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR
NO.
ON THE MOTION REFER.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
I FORTY FOUR KNOWS EIGHTEEN AYE
MOTION CARRIES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY ONE TWENTY TO SEVENTY
FOUR TWENTY OH NINE TWENTY ONE
SIXTY THREE EIGHTEEN NINETY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SIX WITH THE MEMONS
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN WITH
THE MOMENT. TWENTY FIVE NINETY
WITH THE MEMONS TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY BY
FORTY SIX OF THE MOMENTS TWENTY
TWENTY SIX AT THE MOMENT. TWENTY
OH ONE WITH AMENDMENTS ONLY FOR
TWENTY THREE WITH MOMENTS TIME
FOR EIGHTY THROUGH AT THE MOMENT
STATE FOR THIRTY SIX AT THE
MOMENT. NINETEEN SIXTY SIX
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE WITH
LIMITS NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS AT TWENTY FORTY WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
MEMBERS THIS IS BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
ITEMS TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY THREE.
ARE TO BE CONTINUED.
WE ARE MOVING TO THE THIRD
READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX
THIS IS A SEE R. TO A THREE.
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TO A THREE BY SOME A
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND OTHERS
BUILT THE ORGAN AND TISSUE
DONATION.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION TO MISS
QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ACR TWO
ZERO THREE RECOGNIZE A PAROLE AS
DONATE LIFE MONTH WHERE WE
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE ORGAN AND
TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY.
PRIOR TO TO THOUSAND FOR NO
REGISTRY HAD EXISTED FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO WISH TO GIVE
CONSENT TO BE AN ORGAN OR
TISSUE.
DONOR
HISTORICALLY WELL SIGNING A
DONOR CARD IN PLACE IN THE PINK
DOT ON YOUR LICENSE SERVED AS AN
IMPORTANT SYMBOL OF YOUR INTENT.
IT DID NOT PLACE YOU ON ANY LIST
OR REGISTRY HOW MANY OF YOU
REMEMBER THOSE LITTLE PAPER PEEL
OFF DOTS THAT YOU HAD ON YOUR
LICENSE.
AND JULY OF TWO THOUSAND SIX THE
DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA REGISTRY
TOOK A GIANT STEP FORWARD AS IT
BEGAN ITS PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
D. M. V. REPLACING DONOR
STICKERS AND DONOR CARDS.
THIS CONFIDENTIAL DATABASE
ALLOWS CALIFORNIANS TO SHARE
THEIR ORGAN AND TISSUE DONATION
WHICH IS BY REGISTERING ONLINE.
SINCE THEN THE PROGRAM HAS DONE
AN AMAZING JOB OF INCREASING
CALIFORNIA'S REGISTRY ASPIRING
TO THE PROGRAM GOAL THAT
EVERYONE ON THE WAITING LEE LIST
CAN RECEIVE A LIFE SAVING ORGAN
AND HAS A CHANCE TO RECEIVE ONE.
THE DONATE LIFE REGISTRY IS
LITERALLY A LIFESAVING PROGRAM I
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN SUPPORT
OF ACR.
TWO ZERO THREE.
IN MY CITY OF FULLERTON ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I I HAD FIRST
HAND EXPERIENCE WITH WAS A
FAMILY THAT CHAU FAMILY WHOSE
YOUNG DAUGHTER AT THE AGE OF
FIVE YEARS OLD. DROWNED IN A
POOL. A POOL PARTY.
AND HER FAMILY THEN WORKED WITH
DONATE LIFE TO START A. LIKE
DONATE LIFE CLUB ON THE CAMPUS
OF SUNNY HILLS HIGH SCHOOL
MAKING IT ONE OF THE FIRST
DONATE LIFE HIGH SCHOOL CLUBS SO
WITHOUT MEMBERS I ASKED THE
FIRST ROLE OAK TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. AND PLEASE ALSO JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE D. M. V. DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA REGISTRY POOR PROGRAM
THEY ARE APPEAR IN THE GALLERY.
MEMBERS LET'S GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA WILL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
MS QUIRK SILVA IS ASKING THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON AC ARE.
TO.
THREE THIS IS CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS.
MONEY IS HERE TO A THREE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL.
THEIR SIXTY A CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN.
THIS IS A C. ARE TOOL FOR
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO AFFORD AYE FAMILY MEMBER
BAKER RELATIVE TO EQUAL PAY DAY.
MS BAKER YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU TODAY
ACR TWO OH FOR. WHICH
COMMEMORATES APRIL TENTH OF THIS
YEAR AS EQUAL PAY DAY AND NOT
JUST REYES NOW BEHALF OF
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS BUT
ON BEHALF OF EVERY WOMAN AND
GIRL IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ALL WHO BELIEVE IN PAY
EQUITY EVEN THOUGH IT IS ILLEGAL
AT THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL
TO HAVE WAGE DISCRIMINATION THE
GENDER WAGE.
GAP STILL EXISTS AND IT'S VERY
SEVERE IN CALIFORNIA. IN TWENTY
ELEVEN THE GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY
CENTER ON EDUCATION WORKFORCE
FOUND THE COLLEGE EDUCATION
WOMEN WORKING FULL TIME EARNED
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR LESS THAN THEIR
MALE PEERS.
AS RIP SORRY THAT'S OVER THEIR
LIFETIME AS REPORTED BY THE
UNITED STATES CENSUS BUREAU
WOMEN WORKING FULL TIME YEAR
ROUND IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
TYPICALLY EARNED SEVENTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF WHAT MEN EARNED.
AND ACCORDING TO THE REPORT BY
THE NATIONAL PARTNERSHIP FOR
WOMEN AND FAMILIES IN APRIL OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE PAID EIGHTY SIX
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR PAID TO
MEN. THAT AMOUNTS TO AN ANNUAL
WAGE GAP IN OUR STATE OF OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
MISTER CALDERON STAGE A POINT OF
ORDER.
YOU CAN THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS IT IS LOUD ON THE FLOOR
IN A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ON
MEMBER SETTING UP IF WE PLEASE
TAKE OUR SEATS AND GIVE OUR.
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO THE
AUTHOR I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU.
ONE OF OUR IS WELL TAKEN. THANK
YOU I THINK ARE OUR MAJORITY
LEADER FOR THAT AND ALSO WITH
THIS THIS IS IMPORTANT I HOPE
THIS CONVERSATIONS ARE ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN BE DOING TO SUPPORT
PAY EQUITY IN THE WORKPLACE ALL
AROUND CALIFORNIA. SINGLE WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA WITH CHILDREN AND
WOMEN OF COLOR ARE ESPECIALLY
HURT BY THE GENDER WAGE GAP.
ACCORDING TO THE SIMPLE TRUTH
ABOUT THE GENDER PAY GAP A
REPORT BY THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
AND TWENTY FOURTEEN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN IN PARTICULAR
EARNED SIXTY THREE PERCENT AND
LATINA WOMEN EARN FIFTY FOUR
PERCENT OF WHAT MEN EARNED.
NOW CALIFORNIA HAS MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN THIS.
I MEMBERS JUST IN MY FIRST TERM
WE PASSED HISTORIC EQUAL PAY
LEGISLATION THAT SHOULD BE THE
MODEL. ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
THEN AGAIN LAST YEAR WE PASSED
LEGISLATION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ENFORCING THAT BY ENSURING
THAT YOUR PRIOR WAGE DOES NOT
LOCK YOU INTO A LOWER WAGE GOING
INTO NEW. O. JOB THAT YOU MAY
HAVE THERE'S MUCH MORE WORK TO
DO ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE THINGS
WE CAN DO IN CALIFORNIA.
TO SUPPORT PAY EQUITY IN THE
WORKPLACE IS TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR WOMEN TO RETURN TO WORK.
AFTER THEY'VE BEGUN TO START A
FAMILY.
AND THAT MEANS FLEXIBLE WORKWEEK
ARRANGEMENTS FLEXIBLE WORK
SCHEDULES FREEING UP THE RIGID
RIGID RULES WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IMPAIR THE
ABILITY OF EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE TO REACH
AGREEMENTS ON WHAT SCHEDULE
WORKS BEST FOR THEM. BRINGING UP
INNOVATIVE WORKPLACE TECHNOLOGY
SO THAT WOMEN CAN WORK FROM THE
HOME MORE ACTUALLY ALL PARENTS
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK TO DO IN
THIS AND IT IS A BAD THING. THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE GENDER WAGE
GAP THAT WE DO AND THERE'S MORE
THAT WE CAN DO ABOUT IT AND WE
ALL HAVE TO DO IT TOGETHER
REGARDLESS OF WHAT PARTY YOU'RE
A MEMBER OF. THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IN THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS BAKER.
MISTER GIBSON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS ON ACR TWO ZERO
FOUR REGARDING PAY EQUITY FOR
WOMEN. AND WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS GOOD
FOR THIS GOOD A RESOLUTION
BEFORE US. IN OUR CONVERSATION
ON THE DISPARITY IN PAY BETWEEN
WOMEN AND MEN THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF DISPARITY.
BETWEEN BLACK WOMEN AND WOMEN OF
COLOR. THE DATA FROM THE
ECONOMIC POLICY INSTITUTE SHOW
THAT BLACK WOMEN WORK MORE HOURS
ON AVERAGE YET UNFORTUNATELY.
THE GAP IN PAY.
HAS INCREASED OVER TIME.
AND WHILE TWO THIRDS OF BLACK
WOMEN IN THE WORKFORCE HAS SOME
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. AT
ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT HABIT
BASSES AGREE SHE.
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR HIGHER
BLACK WOMEN ARE PAID LESS AT
EVERY LEVEL OF EDUCATION.
IT IS OFTEN SAID THAT IT TAKES A
VILLAGE TO RAISE A CHILD BUT WE
MUST ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT IT
TAKES RESOURCES TO RAISE TO
RAISE A VILLAGE. MONEY IN THE
HANDS OF A WOMAN MEANS NOT FOOD
IN THE BOWELS OF OUR CHILDREN
STABILIZATION ACROSS.
THE COMMUNITY.
WE TALK ABOUT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES LET US
NOT FORGET THE IMPORTANCE OF
PAYING A PAY EQUITY WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE ON
ACR TWO ZERO FOUR.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON MISS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW I SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
CAUCUS IN SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION ON PAY EQUITY BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO TALK
MORE ABOUT WHY WE THINK PAY
EQUITY ARE PAID IN EQUITY IS
WRONG. I THINK THAT'S CLEAR
WOMEN SHOULDN'T MAKE LESS THAN
MEN.
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT.
HOW WE SOLVE THAT ISSUE IN THERE
IS ONE THING THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
WITH OUT A DOUBT THE BEST WAY TO
REDUCE PAY INEQUITY AND THAT IS
BY UNIONIZING MORE WORKERS? WE
KNOW THAT ANY UNIONIZED
WORKFORCE WOMEN MAKE NINETY FOUR
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR OF THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS. THAT'S IN
COMPARISON TO SEVENTY EIGHT
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR IN A NON
UNIONIZED ARE RIGHT IT TOTAL
ENVIRONMENT ACTUALLY. WE KNOW IN
THE FEMALE DOMINATED SERVICE
SECTOR. THAT WOMEN WHO ARE IN
THE UNION MAKE EIGHTY SEVEN
PERCENT MORE WHEN YOU COUNT PAY
AND BENEFITS THAN THEIR NON
UNION COUNTERPARTS WE KNOW THAT
IF YOU WANT TO RAISE UP WOMEN.
THAT YOU ALLOW COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IN ORGANIZING AND YOU
DON'T ATTACK THE EIGHT HOUR DAY
INSTEAD WE DO THINGS THAT ENSURE
THAT ALL WOMEN UNDER. AN
AGREEMENT A CONTRACT HAVE TO BE
PAID AT EQUAL RATES OF THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HIGHER AND
AWAY AGE BRACKETS THAT
TRANSPARENCY LEADS TO PAY
EQUITY.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TODAY WE
TALK ABOUT THE DISPARITIES AND
HOW TERRIBLE IT IS LET'S ALSO
COMMIT OURSELVES TO FINDING WAYS
TO REDUCE THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MR THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR. TWO ZERO FOUR WHICH WILL
PROCLAIM TOMORROW AS EQUAL PAY
DAY.
AS CHAIR OF LABOR AS A FATHER OF
TWO YOUNG GIRLS. I'M COMMITTED
TO ENSURING THAT WOMEN RECEIVE
THE EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
THAT THEY DESERVE.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT REPORTS TODAY
THAT TALK ABOUT THE GAP IN
CALIFORNIA IS BEING EIGHTY SIX
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR. FOR WHAT
WOMEN EARN COMPARED TO MEN THAT
MEANS SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
LESS PER YEAR. THAT MEANS LESS
MONEY TO PAY THE RENT. LESS
MONEY TO PAY THE MORTGAGE AND
SUPPORT WAS FAMILY LESS MONEY
FOR EDUCATION OR FOR SAVING OR
FOR RETIREMENT.
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
DISPROPORTION ALLEY?
IN THIS GAP AND HOW IT IMPACTS
BLACK WOMEN AT A RATE ARE BEING
PAID SIXTY THREE PERCENT.
WHAT MEN ARE AND LATINOS FIFTY
FOUR PERCENT OF WHAT WHITE MEN
ARE?
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN GREAT
STRIDES IN ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
BY ENACTING THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
PAY ACT.
WHICH I WAS PROUD TO SUPPORT. I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TO CLOSE THE PAY GAP AND
ENSURE THAT WOMEN BE SAYER
RECEIVED THE PAY THAT THEY HAVE
EARNED MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING. ACR TWO ZERO FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER.
BERMAN ALL THIS QUESTION HAVING
SEES MS BAKER YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
THANK YOU I THINK OUR COLLEAGUES
FOR THE THOUGHTFUL ADDITIONAL.
WERE TO SUPPORT AND ALL THAT
KIND OF SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN BE
CONSIDERING AND DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE.
GETTING RID OF THE GENDER WAGE
GAP ISN'T JUST A QUESTION OF
FAIRNESS IT'S ALSO ONE OF
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
BECAUSE WOMEN TWO THIRDS OF
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA WHO WORK
OUTSIDE THE HOME ARE THE
PRIMARY.
OR LARGE.
WAGE EARNERS FOR THEIR FAMILIES
THEY'RE THE BREADWINNERS FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND WHEN THEY ARE
PAID LESS WE ARE UNDERMINING
THEIR ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR FAMILIES AND BE ABLE TO
HAVE GOOD ECONOMIC SECURITY IN
OUR STATE.
IN THERE'S A A MYTH OUT THERE
THAT THE WAGE GAP IS THERE JUST
BECAUSE WOMEN DO LEAVE THE WORK
FORCE TO HAVE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
THE WAGE GAP IS EVIDENT IN
CAREERS ACROSS THE BOARD AS
EARLY AS THE FIRST YEAR OUT OF
COLLEGE.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER WE
NEED TO EDUCATE ONE ANOTHER
ABOUT WHAT THE MYTHS ARE THE
CAUSE OF GENDER WAGE DISPARITY
WE NEED TO TACKLE HEAD ON. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTING
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ADDING
HONEST CO AUTHORS.
IT WAS BAKER THE AUTHORS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CALL AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS AND ACR TO A FOR
CLERK WILL FOR THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ADDING ONTO THE
RESOLUTION.
IT'S CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER OAK THERE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE IN ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEMS TWENTY EIGHT.
THROUGH THIRTY TO PASS AND
RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY NINE THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SIXTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ACTUALLY TO PEACE
OFFICERS.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY NINE WELL AT THE PEACE
OFFICER OF CORRECTIONAL SAFETY.
SPECIAL SERVICES UNIT SS YOU AND
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
ALTHOUGH I A WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO PENAL CODE SIX THREE THREE.
MUCH OF THE EVIDENCE GATHERED BY
THE SPECIAL SERVICES UNIT AND
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
AND RETAIN WHILE UNDERCOVER OR
HAPPENSTANCE OR REVEALED
ACCIDENTALLY WITHOUT PRE
PLANNING BUT IS NOT PERMISSIBLE
AS LEGAL EVIDENCE BECAUSE
NEITHER OF THESE. SWORN PEACE
OFFICER INCLUDED IN PENAL CODE
SIX STREET THREE IN ORDER FOR
THE SPECIAL SERVICES UNIT AND
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
TO USE THIS TYPE OF EVIDENCE
WILL REQUIRE THEM TO GET A LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S WARRANT.
PRIDE TO GAINING THE EVIDENCE
THIS IS THIS PROBLEM IS WHY MOST
PIECE OFFICE AGENCIES ARE LISTED
IN. PENAL CODE SIXTY THREE AND
WHY THE SPECIAL SERVICES UNIT
AND THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS OF CDC ARE NEEDED TO BE
EFFORT AT IT. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS JONES SAWYER.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. I
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED IN THE EYES
SEVENTY.
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR.
AB NINETEEN NO THREE
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OH THREE
BY SOME THE MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND ACTUALLY TO FIRE
ARMS.
SKINS DOLLARS FLETCHER YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
AN EASY COMMON SENSE BILL I JUST
PERHAPS IT IT'S GOT BY THAT
PROGRAM'S FROM DISTRIBUTING GIFT
CARDS TO RETAILERS THAT POSSESS
FIREARMS OR AMMUNITION DEALERS
LICENSE.
THIS CAME TO MY ATTENTION IN MY
DISTRICT WHEN AT CHRISTMAS TIME.
THEY WERE DOING A GUN BUY BACK
PROGRAM OR GIVING OUT GIVE CARDS
TO A RETAILER THAT IN FACT.
IS THE LARGEST RETAILER SELLING
AMMUNITION IN THE COUNTRY AYE IT
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IS PEOPLE TURNING GUNS IF THAT'S
OUR PURPOSE THAT THAT WE WANT TO
TAKE GUNS OFF OF OUR STREET THAT
WE'RE NOT ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
GO PLACES WHERE THEY CAN
PURCHASE. NEW GUNS OR AMMUNITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. ARE RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN OH THREE AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
INTRODUCING THIS GOOD
COMMONSENSE PIECE F LEGISLATION.
CITIES AND COUNTIES OPERATE
BUYBACK PROGRAMS TO KEEP GUNS
OFF THE STREETS BY GIVING
INDIVIDUAL GIFT CARDS TO
BUSINESSES THAT SELL GUNS AND
AMMUNITION.
THIS DEFEATS THE PURPOSE. AND
SO WHEN I THINK THE THE WOMAN
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR COMING WITH
HIS GOOD PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO PLEASE
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
OH THREE.
THEY WAS GIPSON MISTER ALLEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THIS IS A TERRIBLE BILL.
THERE'S ACTUALLY NO REASON WE
SHOULD BE DOING OF VOLUNTARY
FIREARMS BUYBACK PROGRAMS IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
AND SECONDARILY I IF ANY OF OUR
RETAILERS WANT TO GIVE BACK GIFT
CARDS WE SHOULDN'T BE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST THOSE
THAT ARE HELPING US PARTICIPATE.
AND THEN USING OUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS WHICH ARE
RIGHTS NOT OUR PRIVILEGES AND
THOSE SHALL NOT BE INFRINGED BY
THIS BODY OR ANY OTHER UNITED
STATES.
ARJUNA VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ARISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TURN IN ONE GUN. GET A
GIFT CERTIFICATE TO GO TO
ANOTHER PLACE GOT MAYBE BY
BIGGER GUN WHEN THEY COULD DO A
LITTLE BIT MORE DAMAGE THE
REASONABLE COMMON SENSE MEASURE
RESPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS CALLED AROUND.
ALL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE HAVING
CEASED.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER I THINK
ALL DEBATE HAS CEASED.
THANK YOU THIS IS NOT A VOTE ON
WHETHER OR NOT YOU LIKE THE GUN
BUY BACK PROGRAM IT'S A VOTE ON
WHETHER IN ITS EXISTENCE IF WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY. BE GIVING
PEOPLE.
IN EXCHANGE FOR MAY BE A NON
WORKING DONE AN OLD GUY IN A.
ILLEGAL GUN AND THE THE REVENUE
TO GO PURCHASE OR GIFT CARD TO
GO PURCHASE EIGHT NEW. WORKING
GUY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT CLARK LIBERAL. ON
MEMBERS VOTERS HAVE A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A TECHNICAL ISSUE AND
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN MOMENTARILY
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ISSUE RESOLVED.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ON ICE
FORTY NINE THOSE NINETEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSED.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE PASS RETAIN THAT
BRINGS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY SIX.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX THE
CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER THE MOAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MS LIMON YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MANY OF US HAVE HEARD OF
THE HEALTH BENEFITS OF
BREASTFEEDING FOR BOTH BABY AND
PARENT INCLUDING IMPROVED
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT FOR
INFANTS WHILE LOWERING INCIDENCE
OF RESPIRATORY ILLNESS.
AND DISEASES AND ALLERGIES AMONG
OTHER POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
IN BREASTFEEDING PARENTS THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL HAS
REPORTED LOWER RISK FOR BREAST
AND OVARIAN CANCER DIABETES
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE AND OTHER
SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITION.
DESPITE THE MANY ESTABLISHED
BENEFITS TO BENEFITS OF
BREASTFEEDING THE PERCENTAGES.
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
BREASTFEEDING I'M IN THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS REMAINS LOW WOMEN
FREQUENTLY SITE.
THE INABILITY TO BREAST FEED IN
A WORK ENVIRONMENT INCLUDING THE
LACK OF PRIVACY AND HYGIENIC
SPACES AND REASONS FOR IT AS
REASONS FOR DISCONTINUING
BREASTFEEDING.
WITH MORE AND MORE WOMEN WORKING
OUTSIDE THE HOME THIS PRESENTS A
REAL PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE SPACE NEED BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO WOMEN TO
EXPRESSED BREAST MILK IN THE
WORKPLACE.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX IS A
SMALL CHANGE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR WORKING
MOTHERS IN TWO WAYS
ONE ADELINE ST STATUE WITH
FEDERAL LAW SAFEGUARDING THIS
IMPORTANT PROTECTION AGAINST ANY
CHANGES. TO THE ACA AND TO IT
HELPS TO REDUCE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER THAT PERVADES PREVENTS
WOMAN FROM CONTINUING TO
BREASTFEED UPON RETURNING TO
WORK BY ENSURING THAT THERE IS A
PRIVATE AND CLEAN SPACE
AVAILABLE TO EXPRESS.
BREAST MILK.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX IS NOT
OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE IN WHAT
LACTATION ACCOMMODATIONS LOOK
LIKE AND AIMS TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN ENSURING THAT
BREASTFEEDING PARENTS HAVE A
SAFE AND CLEAN SPACE WHILE NOT
OVER BURDENING. EMPLOYERS.
MANY OF YOU HAVE ASKED ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF THAT ABOUT
BATHROOM AND ARCA OUR OFFICE IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION. ON THE
DEFINITION OF THE BATHROOM AND
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT ALL AREAS OF
A WORK SPACE ARE CONSIDERED
INCLUDING RURAL. AND ALSO CITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS LIMON.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE BILL BEFORE THE BODY.
FOR CLUB GIRL ON MEMBERS OF.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI THAT I FIFTY SIX
KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT AND THIRTY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY?
THIS IS AC ARE TO ELEVEN BY
MISTER FRAZIER THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO ELEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER
FRAZIER RELATIVE TO DISTRACTED
DRIVING.
MISTER FRAZIER EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
ARE PERCENT AC OR. TWO ONE ONE
DESIGNATING APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
AS DISTRACTED DRIVING AWARENESS
MONTH AND IN CALIFORNIA.
ACR TWO TWO ONE ONE CALLS FOR
AWARENESS OF THE DANGERS OF
DISTRACTED DRIVING AND SUPPORT
FOR PROGRAMS AND POLICIES TO
REDUCE THE INCIDENCE.
OF DISTRACTED DRIVING.
TRAFFIC FATALITIES CAUSED BY
DISTRACTED DRIVING A RAPIDLY
INCREASING CALIFORNIA AND AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF TRAFFIC SAFETY.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THREE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
PEOPLE WERE KILLED AND THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE THOUSAND
WERE INJURED NATIONWIDE. IN
ACCIDENTS WERE DISTRACTED
DRIVING WITH SIDE IS A
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE CAUSE.
DISTRACTED DRIVING PUTS ALL OF
US AT RISK EVERY DAY AND IT MUST
STOP.
WHEN WE WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER TO
EDUCATE OURSELVES AND OUR LOVED
ONES WE CAN MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER
AND AND SAVE THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
I URGE ALL RESIDENTS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO DO THEIR
PART TO SPREAD AWARENESS OF THE
DANGERS OF DISTRACTED DRIVING.
YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF. IRONIC
THAT WE HAVE A THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINE.
FOR LITTERING BUT A TEN DOLLAR
FINE FOR DISTRACTED DRIVING.
WHEN YOU DO THAT.
CAN KILL MANY PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T OF COURSE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY DRIVE SAFELY AND
DISTRACTION FREE ARE ON A ROADS
WE NEED TO HAVE A DETERRENT.
I ASKED THE FIRST WORLD WE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR RIVAL.
THINGS FRAZIER.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
YOUR FRAZIER YOU WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLE
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION CARPOOL OPEN
ROLL-ON.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ON ACR TO ELEVEN CO AUTHORS.
ADDING ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL.
THERE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY ONE H. R. NINETY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY FIVE BY
SOME THEM I BURKE AND OTHERS
RELATIVE AND NATIONAL DAY FOR
MATERNAL HEALTH RIGHTS.
THIS BURKE EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT YOU HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY FIVE.
EACH ARE NINETY FIVE DECLARES
APRIL ELEVENTH AS THE
INTERNATIONAL DAY FOR MATERNAL
HEALTH AND RIGHTS EACH ARE NOT
HR NINETY FIVE ALSO URGES UNITED
NATIONS TO SUPPORT.
COMPREHENSIVE RESPECTFUL AND
RATES BASED MATERNAL HEALTH BY
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZING THIS DAY
AND BY DOING SO. SIGNALING TO
THE WORLD. THAT THE UNITED
NATION INTENDS TO INCREASE
AWARENESS ON THE HEALTH AND
RIGHTS OF WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
MEMBERS EVERY WOMAN SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO ACCESS SKILLED
HEALTH CARE DURING PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH. EVERYONE WOMEN
SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO BE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT DURING
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH. BUT
WOMAN ACROSS THE GLOBE ARE
FREQUENTLY MISTREATED JUDGED
ABUSED AND DENIED BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS.
INTERNATIONAL DAY FOR MATERNAL
HEALTH AND RIGHTS CAN RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE NEEDS TO
PROVIDE WOMEN AND BABIES WITH
DIGNIFIED CARE. BUT ACHIEVE IT
WITH REQUIRING DEEP SOUL
SEARCHING RISK DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE UNDERLYING CAUSES OF THIS
ABUSE.
HR NINETY FIVE CALLS ON A GLOBAL
COMMUNITY INTERNATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD TO PROMOTE
AND SUPPORT MATERNAL HEALTH AND
RIGHTS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS BURKE DOCTOR WEBER
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
YES MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
RISE ON BEHALF OFTHE.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR NINETY
FIVE RECOGNIZING APRIL ELEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS
INTERNATIONAL DAY FOR MATERNAL
HEALTH AND RIGHTS.
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BILL
A RESOLUTION THAT SOMETIMES WE
FORGET ABOUT.
MY DAUGHTER IS A.
OBGYN.
SHE OFTEN SAYS THAT CHILDBIRTH
IS STILL AS DANGEROUS AS IT WAS
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE CENTURY.
THE REALITY IS IT'S LESS
DANGEROUS BECAUSE WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME KIND OF CARE FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE PROCESS BUT
ONE. WOULD COMMUNITIES DO NOT
GET ADEQUATE PRENATAL CARE AND
SUPPORT. THAT WE HAVE TRAGEDY
THAT SEVERE. CALIFORNIA OF THE
UNITED STATES RATHER UNITED
STATES HAS NEARLY UP THREE TIMES
MORE THE CHILDREN WILL DIE.
FROM.
FROM BASICALLY A WOMEN WILL DIE
FROM CHILDBIRTH EIGHT HUNDRED
WOMEN ALL ACROSS THE NATION WILL
DIE EVERYDAY FROM CHILDBIRTH.
AND THE UNITED STATES IT WITH
ALL OF ITS SOPHISTICATED
MEDICAL.
INFORMATION AS WELL AS
FACILITIES WE STILL HAD LEFT FAR
BEHIND MOST OF THE OF THE
WEALTHY DEVELOPED COUNTRIES IN
THE WORLD WHEN IT COMES CHILD
BIRTH AND DEATH FROM CHILDBIRTH.
THE TRAGEDY IS ALSO THAT IT IS
MAGNIFIED BY THOSE WHO ARE POOR
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO HAVE
ACCESS WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO
PRENATAL CARE. AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT THE BLACK INFANT
MORTALITY IS BASICALLY TWICE
THAT OF THE WHITE POPULATION IN
THE STATION. AND BASICALLY IS
COMPARABLE TO THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES SO IS VERY IMPORTANT
AS WE THINK ABOUT IT BECAUSE
MOST OF US DON'T THINK
CHILDBIRTH IS A DANGEROUS THING
AND YET IT CAN BE. IT IS NOT
PROPERLY CARED FOR IT WAS ALWAYS
NUMBER ONE KILLER OF WOMEN IN
THE EARLY PART OF THE CENTURY
AND SO WE'RE MOVING MORE IN THAT
DIRECTION BY NOT TAKING INTO
SUSAN'S AS WE COULD. AND
BASICALLY MAKING SURE THAT ALL
POPULATIONS HAVE ACCESS TO
PRENATAL CARE THAT'S GOOD TO
HEAR THAT ALLOWS THE BABY TO BE
BORN HEALTHY AS WELL AS A MOTHER
TO SURVIVE THE PREGNANCY. IN A
HEALTHY STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR HR NINETY
FIVE WE ARE DEVELOPED COUNTRY
AND OUR WOMEN AND CHILDREN
SHOULD FEEL THE MAGNITUDE OF.
ALL THE RESEARCH AND WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE BY PROVIDING THE
HEALTH CARE OF US SO WE CENTRAL
AT BIRTH THANK YOU. FOR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION.
I MISS BURKE YOU'D LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THIS MISS BURKE IS
ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR
NINETY FIVE THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
IS CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE RATHER SIXTY
THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THAT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
AND MS BURKE I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
SOME GUEST WITH US RELATIVE TO
THIS HOUSE.
RESOLUTION OF JOIN US IN THE
CHAMBER MS BURKE HERE RECOGNIZE
THINK YOU IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE GINA ARIEL WHO IS A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE AND
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION.
GINA RECEIVED HER BACHELOR'S IN
NURSING FROM SAN FRANCISCO STATE
A MATCH WHERE A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN MIDWIFE METHOD FOR YOU FROM
YOU SEE S. OUT.
MIDDLE AS CLEAN A CENTRAL
MATERNAL CARE ACROSS THE WORLD
AND HEARING CALIFORNIA THEIR
MISSION IS TO PROMOTE THE HEALTH
OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN THROUGH
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY CARE.
TO SAY THAT IN FACILITATE THE
INTEGRATION OF NURSE MIDWIVES
INTO THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING I MEAN TINA AERIALS OF
HOW CHRIST IS.
YEAH FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY TWO
IS PASS AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS
US TO CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACTUALLY THE
TRUSTS.
WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT POUNDER.
OUR MEMBERS PHOTO ABOUT THIS A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER OR SEVENTY ONE.
I VOTES THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WE ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFFER THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR WE ARE AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION.
SPEAK.
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF BONNIE RES A LONG TIME
PUBLIC SERVANT AND ADVISER TO GO
TO FORMER GOVERNOR ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER.
AND WHO PLAYED A PIVOTAL ROLE IN
THE SCHWARZENEGGER
ADMINISTRATION.
BORN IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE IN
NEW YORK CITY REECE GRADUATED
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI AND
RECEIVE HER LAW DEGREE FROM
ANTIOCH SCHOOL OF LAW IN
WASHINGTON DC.
WHILE IN LAW SCHOOL REESE WORKED
MASSACHUSETTS SENATOR TED
KENNEDY. AND LATER WORKED ON HIS
NINETEEN EIGHTY PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS THERE THAT SHE MET MARIA
SHRIVER.
WITH WHOM SHE WOULD REMAIN
LIFELONG FRIENDS.
REESE LATER MET SCHWARZENEGGER
THROUGH SHRIVER.
AND DESCRIBE BOTH AS HER FAMILY.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE RESPECT
CALIFORNIAN BEGAN A CAREER IN
ENTERTAINMENT LAW.
POLITICS AND PUBLIC SERVICE
HOWEVER WERE NEVER FAR FROM HER
MIND AND SHE REMAINED ENGAGED IN
POLITICAL ADVOCACY. HELPING
FOUND THE HOLLYWOOD WOMEN'S
POLITICAL COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS
THE EARTH COMMUNICATIONS OFFICE
WHICH WORK TO INCREASE
ENVIRONMENTAL AWARENESS IN
POPULAR CULTURE.
REESE WAS ALSO PASSIONATE ABOUT
EDUCATION AND BEGAN WORKING WITH
SCHWARZENEGGER. AS THE FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF HIS NONPROFIT AFTER
SCHOOL ALL STARS WHICH SOUGHT TO
INCREASE AFTER SCHOOL
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR LOW INCOME
AND AT RISK YOUTH.
RES A LIBERAL DEMOCRATS SERVED
AS AN ADVISER TO
SCHWARZENEGGERFROM TWO THOUSAND
THREE TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND HELPED SHAPE
HIS POLICY AGENDA ON EDUCATION
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. MOST
NOTABLY.
SHE PLAYED A PIVOTAL ROLE IN THE
PASSAGE OF AB THIRTY TWO.
AFTER BRIEFLY LEAVINGTHE
SCHWARZENEGGER ADMINISTRATION
AND RETURNING HOME TO MALIBU.
REESE WAS APPOINTED TO BE
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION AND ALSO
SERVED AS THE UC REGENT.
THROUGHOUT HER CAREER WHETHER IN
PUBLIC SERVICE OR NONPROFIT WORK
SHE WAS KNOWN FOR HER
EFFECTIVENESS AND COMMITMENT TO
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS.
IN A STATEMENT SCHWARZENEGGER
DESCRIBED HER AS A TRUE TREASURE
TO CALIFORNIA IN THE UNITED
STATES THE WORLD. AND EVERYONE
SHE HAS EVER MET.
A FELLOW UC REGENT SHERRY
LANSING DESCRIBED HER AS.
CONSCIENCE OF THE REGENTS.
REESE PASSED AWAY IN HER MALIBU
HOME LAST MONDAY AT THE AGE OF
SIX
TWO AFTER YOUR LONG BATTLE WITH
LUNG CANCER.
SCHWARZENEGGER SAID EVERY STEP.
SHE WAS BORN TO SHAKE THE STATUS
QUO TO ITS CORE.
AND SHAPE THE WORLD.
AND SHE CERTAINLY DID
BECAUSE AS WE REFLECT ON HER
LASTING IMPACT
WHICH INCLUDES SHAPING ONE OF
THE MOST INTERNATIONALLY
CONSEQUENTIAL PIECES OF
ENVIRONMENTAL LEGISLATION. AB
THIRTY TO AN IMPROVING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR STUDENTS.
WE CAN CONFIDENTLY SAY. THAT SHE
DID EXACTLY THAT.
AND I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
MISTER LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I RISE TO A JOURNEY MEMORY OF
DOCTOR CAN A CENTRALLY.
WHO LOST HIS LIFE?
I'M SORRY. AND HIS BATTLE WITH
CANCER ON MARCH TWENTY FIFTH.
DOCTOR CENTER ONLY WAS LONGTIME
DIRECTOR THE ANTELOPE VALLEY
ENGINEERING PROGRAM. WHICH IS A
SATELLITE CAMPUS FOR CSU LONG
BEACH.
WITHOUT HIM THE PROGRAM NEVER
WOULD'VE MATERIALIZED.
DOCTOR SAID REALLY WAS ABLE TO
BUILD KEY PARTNERSHIPS WITH CSU
FRESNO THE LATER CSU LONG BEACH
TO GET ESTABLISHED.
HE ONE GRANTS TO BUILD UP IN ITS
EARLY DAYS WAS LATER
INSTRUMENTAL. TO RECEIVING AN A.
B. E. T. ACCREDITATION.
FOR ELECTRICAL AND MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING PROGRAMS.
UNDER DOCTOR'S CENTER CENTRAL IS
LEADERSHIP YELLOW BELLY CAMPUS
TRAINED MANY ENGINEERS.
THE PROGRAM BOASTS AN EXTREMELY
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AFTER
GRADUATION WHICH IS SERVE TO
BOLSTER ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
SECTOR. OF MY COMMUNITIES
ECONOMY.
PRIOR TO HIS TIME IS AN EDUCATOR
DOCTOR SAID REALLY HAD A LONG
CAREER WORKING. FOR THE AERO JET
ROCKETDYNE INCLUDING SERVING AS
DIRECTOR OF MANUFACTURING AND
TEST FOR THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE
STATION ELECTRIC POWER SYSTEM.
SO HIS WORKERS.
STILL REFLECTED ON SYSTEMS IN
USE TODAY.
ON THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE
STATION.
IS COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT WHAT
WELL BEYOND HIS RESPONSIBILITIES
WITH THE SCHOOL.
HE WAS A CO CHAIR FOR THE AB
BOARD OF TRADE'S EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HE ALSO SAT ON THE AB
COLLEGE. ADVISORY COUNCIL.
JURORS CALLED CONTRIBUTIONS TO
AEROSPACE HE WAS AN HONORARY
COMMANDER FOR THE AIRFORCE
FLIGHT TEST CENTER AT EDWARDS
AIRFORCE BASE.
OUR COMMUNITY WAS FORTUNATE TO
HAVE A LEADER WITH DOCTOR SENT
TO RELEASE.
SPURIOUS AND CHARACTER.
HE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY HIS
STUDENTS COLLEAGUES AND THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME TODAY AND
ADJOURNING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
APRIL TENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY APRIL ELEVENTH CHECK
IN SESSION. THURSDAY APRIL
TWELFTH FLOOR SESSION
IT'S AT NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED AND
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
HOLDEN MOVES.
AND MR LACKEY SECOND STEP THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY APRIL TWELFTH.
AND NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED